since 2010 under the conservatives we've
seen arrests halved prosecutions halved
convictions half Community penalties
half court delays at record highs and
record numbers of victims giving up on
the criminal justice system and dropping
out and the prosecution rate has
plummeted by a shocking two-thirds since
2015 with only one in 20 recorded crimes
now charged so quite literally that
means more criminals are getting away
with it after 13 years of conservative
government and the Home Secretary is
doing nothing to turn that around then
that collapse of prosecution started in
2015 successive home secretaries have
just Shrugged their shoulders and failed
to act
on policing the Home Secretary is absent
too
across the country I have met dedicated
and brave police officers who are doing
a brilliant job to keep people safe
neighborhood offices and pcsi as I spoke
to yesterday in Milton Keynes who are
working incredibly hard to tackle knife
crime which has risen sharply in the
area
response officers that I've spoken to in
Yorkshire
who risk their own lives to stop a
dangerous machete attacker or the
detectives in merseyside I spoke to
working night and day to solve and
investigate homicide and organized crime
but for all that dedication and hard
work public confidence in policing has
fallen and according to some surveys by
20 in just two years